going back to the beginning when you
first had a twinkle in your eye thinking
about filmmaking what questions would
you have wanted to ask a tiff alum a
Sundance alum someone who has
distribution hmm it's a very good
question thank you here we go can we go
to the howard stern so you just kind of
war is this an icebreaker yeah this is
gonna be skint very difficult and oh
yeah what were you asked um fluffy I
think just like understanding the entire
distribution process like like to have
just making the film is just step one
and then the distribution of the entire
film is like a whole other monster so
the more you're the distributor allows
you to be involved is great like we're
working with you're watching right now
and they've they're very open about how
things are being shared and how things
are getting out there and I think that's
very cool to know and I would definitely
go back and ask some people like what's
the best way to get word of mouth out
there to raise awareness especially when
you're dealing in the indie feature
world where there's not a lot of money
for PA and stuff like that so just
knowing how to create a nice grassroots
campaign I think would be a good
question to to have an answer to and to
get the word out for the movie I don't
know if it's a question necessarily but
I think one of the things that we learn
every time we make something is just how
many steps there are two the process it
feels like it feels like it's all about
just being on set and making the thing
and what you forget especially with
something small that doesn't have this
huge machine built around it to help it
actually become a finished product that
there are so many parts of the process
and I think that we're always surprised
just not even necessarily how long but
just how much how much sustained effort
is needed to
just like a second you actually think
it's done there's always that extra
three percent and that three percent is
where the movie but becomes finished
it's like where you get your sound mix
and your color correction like you want
it you want it to be you want it to be
done so bad and like you're so ready to
have a fit but there's always that like
last hurdle with everything that we've
ever done there's been that sort of sort
of like blast stage and I think that um
I think that just like having like to
get the advice of just stick it out it's
going to you're going to like hate your
movie by the end because you're going to
want it to be done so bad I mean I we
still learn that every single time we
make something um I think that it's AI
mean it's interesting because I think in
hindsight there's the there's always
stuff that you know you would be smarter
about you know going in attacking again
but I think that it's also what's one of
those things to speak in what Tyler was
saying like if you knew everything that
needed to be done going into it from the
beginning and knew that you had to like
do it again it would be like prohibitive
in a weird play and there's something
about like not knowing what's gonna come
your way go to our bed that's kind of
like an integral part of the process
because I feel like it's sort of a
necessary question you know it's sort of
necessary wild card just like that's
what like if you if you knew like how
tough some things were gonna be I think
going into it it might be like kind of
too scary to think like I don't know if
I can even get through that but you do
but part of it is because you don't
quite know like how in over your head
you are a lot of the times and like and
then you just and then you kind of find
yourself being a lot more capable doing
stuff you know then maybe you would even
give yourself credit for I'll never
forget I would we were location scouting
sky at the same time for you know me for
like the radio silent segments and he
for him for his segment and you were in
palmdale i think i was in i think i was
up north rosamond or in like pair
pear pear blossom oh sure yeah for that
was and I had a call with you we were
like you were that you were like days
away from shooting and you needed a
location and we were panicking because
we had 12 locations and hadn't had
hadn't locked in anything and we had
this like really honest conversation
about like if I drove my car off the
road do you think the but maybe the
movie not have to happen if I just drove
my car I was one of those it was one of
those kind of moments but I'm glad that
we locked our location yeah we nailed it
we got like all the locations we got
everything that we needed to do too
obviously to make it happen it's crazy
it's crazy how stuff comes together when
you just keep but I mean like if you
knew going into it it's pretty wild
going back same time any questions you
would have asked yourself about where
you are now I know that seems really
like out there and weird but I mean I
think I think the hardest thing is just
being proactive right and I mean we
certainly live in a time now where the
only limitation is is yourself you know
anyone can grab a camera now and make
something and I think that for certainly
for the radio silence guys and I think
definitely for this film in particular
being being accountable creatively to a
group of people that we all that felt
really cohesive and really like a family
I think was at the heart of how this
movie got got finished I think if you if
you are if you aren't really like in
love with the idea and in love with the
people that you're making the idea with
it's the those two things they have to
those things have to be in place for you
to feel like you're going to actually
finish finish the project and we just
like somehow had this magical experience
as a group on this movie and I think
that that really pushed it pushed it
through to the end
mm-hmm how much confidence versus
uncertainty do you all have now about
your filmmaking career question but I
mean it's such a great town because
things can happen so fast for short
maybe they do take a few years and you
seem like an overnight success but then
at some point some of the stuff dies
down and we all know that there's like
abs and flow so how how confident how
excited or cautious do you all feel well
I definitely think there's an inherent
uncertainty involved in it I mean when
you're putting yourself out there and
putting something out there to create
for people to critique and for people to
watch or to be entertained with I think
there's always going to be an
uncertainty factor involved i think the
confidence comes in like we'll get the
next project done like let's just find a
way to get something done and keep
moving forward to keep making things and
learn something every step of the way i
think we're very actually i'm actually
this group especially all the filmmakers
on southbound i think very proud of all
of them because literally everything was
stacked against us to get the movie made
and we found a way to get it done and
actually get it out there and make it to
the festival circuit which i think it
was it wasn't over accomplishment from
when we started out just being like a
group of friends saying hey let's go
make something that will be fun you know
and i think we're happy with where the
movie came and we're excited for the
life that it lives on after this because
now that we've done our due diligence
we've done the work like every step of
the way what I was Tyler was talking
about earlier like how you never and Pat
was talking about you never realized how
many steps there are but now that it's
done southbound will be out there
forever and we'll get a look back on it
in a couple years ago that was cool we
are able to do that you know and have a
good time with it so there's always a
nice mixture of both uncertainty and
confidence i think in anything any
project move forward no matter how big
horse you know that usually but i think
ultimately like the only real confidence
you can control is your the confidence
you have in your ability to tell to like
make something right that the only time
you have you asked and not this then
this existed to varying degrees on you
know the whole spectrum of like working
on a low budget or no budget anything to
working on the biggest studio thing
things can things can get taken away
it really really easily the thing that
feels like a sure bet can disappear
overnight so at the end of the day the
only thing you really have confidence
wise is you're confident the confidence
in like the idea or what you're capable
of what you're capable of creating and
certainly like every process shakes you
in that way shakes that confidence to a
certain extent but I think that that's
we kind of know that we're onto
something cool when that's shaken a
little bit it's like oh we're sort of
challenging ourselves either with how
little money the story we're trying to
tell with with the small budget or you
know the concept whatever that is I
think that it's also important to kind
of be to kind of be a little
uncomfortable and challenged in the
process that maybe the whole things
happen when when you feel that way
absolutely do you get nervous when
things are too easy a little bit like I
think like if something goes super clean
then you start to I feel like you start
to wonder like every knot winds the
bottom where you get exactly you're
waiting for the other shoe to drop and
it kind of feels like I mean it's to a
certain degree I'm it you know stuff
should be challenging enough like Tyler
was saying where you feel like you're
you're onto something that's actually
like you know engaging in a good way but
then if you find yourself you know like
having a lot of adversity then you sort
of have to wonder you have to take a
minute and be like are we is this what
are we doing this the wrong way like is
there you know do we just do something
kind of stupid and we need to reassess
really quick if it's too hard or if it's
like you just you know sort of trying to
move the production in a way that's like
against the way a production should move
you know things like that but I think
that also if you are just having like a
real clean smooth thing then sometimes I
tend to wonder like if maybe like yeah
when's the other shoe gonna drop or like
what it you know kind of looking over
your shoulder for that I remember like
the early stages of just getting this
project through pre-production there
were multiple conversations had in like
the weeks the week leading up to your
chute which was the first thing where we
were like we were all I think secretly
wanting it to push yeah like we didn't
have the time yeah to really pull it
together the way we wanted to and we
were all like we all wanted wanted the
movie to happen and there was also the
sphere that if we push that we would
just kind of keep keep pushing you
pushing it yeah I'm super glad that we
didn't that we just pulled the trigger
on it yeah we did but there was there is
definitely there was definitely time for
a psych re really it was just the smart
thing like I do we have so many things
stacked against us that didn't
ultimately I think you know it was just
a matter of doing what we could with the
resources that we had mmm in a
collaboration like this who gets to pick
the camera I well Tyler yeah Tyler had a
brought to the table a couple of options
but we ultimately as a group sort of
decided like you know yeah like so it
was it was one of those it was also a it
was sort of what would be the most
practical choice essentially for what we
wanted to pull off is really I think
it's kind of what it came down to yeah
we were we originally were going to
shoot on the Amira which is an Alexa
camera that only shoots 16 by 9 and then
the conversation happened that we wanted
to shoot with anamorphic lenses and it
didn't make sense to be on that camera
so it's sort of in a weird way like this
style the style that we all came to
collectively as a group really enforced
and really dictated the camera the
camera that we chose and certainly like
the speed that we had to shoot with it
was all about making it as lean and mean
and quick to you know quick to set up
and take down as possible what was the
temperature like and I know you shot him
at Palmdale Lancaster on 29 palms what
was the temperature like and did anybody
kind of freaked out from the heat it
wasn't I mean when we shot we shot
almost primarily night and it was like
you know beginning of the year it was
well it was pretty cool like I desert so
I had I mean these brave guys were
essentially hanging out completely naked
in like high desert in the middle of the
night so it was like 30 to 40 degrees
and and again like almost all that stuff
was it was big basically in 30s and 40s
while we were shooting because we had no
daytime stuff so is pretty chilly yeah
so in the beginning know what cuz I know
what the desert like there's such a
temperature change when we were setting
up there was no like
cycle it wasn't too bad no I mean
honestly wasn't too hot like when we
were shooting in days just because it
was februari so you guys got some rain
though right oh we had rain like the
second day in like historical drought we
were like it was like the only time a
train was during our exterior shooting
days it was like of course of course it
would be raining on that day um but
dodged every weather bullet for our
pieces we can be pretty soon we had iron
what was it like 70 upper 70s during the
day and then like 50s at night we
couldn't have asked asked for and gotten
a better a better situation gentlemen
you had talked about in a prior
interview staying true to your content
but also working with brands and
incorporating that into your content no
you have a very successful YouTube
channel and I'm wondering what your
thoughts are and what your advice is to
other Creators on staying true to your
brand being able to make a lifestyle
from doing the videos but also
incorporating paid sponsorship I think
brands are actually kind of cool now a
lot cooler than they used to be I think
that they're friendly getting the
content creation element to it so as
long as the creators are staying true to
their content and incorporating the
brand rather than highlighting the brand
or making it seem like it was just for
the brand I think is a cool approach to
do it where you can get a paycheck for
yourself you can get your production
funded and also you can work in the
brand placement and I subtle way rather
than hitting your viewers over the head
with it but ultimately it just comes
down to staying true to your vision and
staying true to your followers and being
communicative with everybody that out
there that to let them know like you
know we have this coming up from the
great people of coca-cola or you know
whoever the brand is you're not making
Matthew McConaughey Lincoln commercials
but you're making you know something
that your viewers would expect you to
make and incorporating the brand that
way yeah I mean I think it's brands are
much more like the storytelling of
commercials is a much bigger thing now
than it is I feel like even you know I
and in part of it I think is the
evolution that commercials are sort of
disappearing a little bit with the
of these kind of digital platforms
advertising is going to have to be more
brands are going to have to be naturally
more integrated into things because
there are fewer people like watching
actual you know advertisements on you
know cable TV or network TV clicking
that's part of it I also think is going
to sound kind of rash but I think the
idea of like selling out is kind of
it's like this weird sort of I
don't know this Western idea that like
you can love you can love a creator and
then the second that they're actually
able to support themselves doing what
they do you like that makes their
creating less less interesting I think
that's kind of a weird like up
myth that is like of I don't know this
kind of just a weird creation I tonight
so I think I was necessary eggs yeah
exactly it's like why why not support
the person who I who finally like gets
to do the thing gets paid to do the
thing that they love to do I it's sort
of a strange relationship but if you
know any brands were looking at you guys
watching this